[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy Este es el
programa feminista de France 24 y en
esta ocasión para conmemorar el día
internacionales de los derechos de la
mujer Tendremos una emisión especial en
la que les mostraremos algunas de las
mayores luchas que se mantienen en
América Latina nuestros corresponsales
en la región nos trajeron las historias
y vamos a comenzar con Guatemala allí
grupos de derechos humanos alertan de
niveles de violencia contra las mujeres
extremadamente altos las más vulnerables
son las menores de edad con 23 casos
diarios de abusos sexuales a niñas y
adolescentes según el fondo de la ONU
para la infancia además muchos casos se
quedan sin registrar porque nunca llegan
a denunciarse una superviviente de
violencia sexual acudió a nuestra
corresponsal en Centroamérica Aurora
bayus y le contó su historia
esta joven guatemalteca dice que tejer
estas pulseras le permite escapar de sus
pensamientos cuando tenía 13 años Fue
violada cinco veces por el pastor de su
pueblo después de meses de acoso sexual
el insomnio las ganas de no comer todas
las noches me ponía a llorar y decía que
por qué a mí Dios estuvo ahí conmigo al
que no quedara embarazada en el país
centroamericano se reportan cada día 23
abusos sexuales a niñas y adolescentes y
las víctimas no encuentran en Guatemala
un sistema de Justicia cooperativo dos
años después de los hechos la
sobreviviente cuenta un proceso lento y
desgastante su agresor fue condenado a
26 años de cárcel pero todavía sigue
libre
no no me parece un proceso fácil porque
el psicólogo me preguntaba cosas que
ella no quería recordar me hicieron
quitarme la ropa me investigaron
ante este drama que viven miles de niñas
en el país la asociación asogen les
brinda apoyo legal para presentar las
denuncias así como talleres de
empoderamiento económico vienen de zonas
muy vulnerables es decir que son de
escasos recursos personas analfabetas
que no tienen ningún grado de Educación
normalmente son personas que tienen una
dependencia económica en mayor parte de
su agresor esa violencia se refleja en
otras cifras en 2022 según el
observatorio en salud sexual y
reproductiva se registraron más de
67.000 embarazos de niñas entre 10 y 19
años para frenar esa violencia su gente
necesario reforzar las políticas para la
prevención de embarazos sin embargo en
Guatemala se impulsó el año pasado una
iniciativa de ley que intentaba prohibir
la educación sexual en las escuelas
en México que es uno de los países con
un mayor índice de feminicidio los
ataques a mujeres con ácido son cada vez
más visibles la sobreviviente se luchan
para que estas agresiones se castiguen
como un intento de feminicidio El
Congreso ha inscrito una iniciativa
bautizada como ley Malena para Elevar
las penas por este tipo de violencia
nuestro corresponsal en Ciudad de México
Mario carbón Elena nos presenta la
historia
María Elena Rio sobrevivió a un intento
de feminicidio tras un ataque con ácido
en septiembre de 2019 hoy ya puede
volver a tocar el saxofón pero superar
la agresión ha sido tortuoso te ves muy
grave de salud
te encontrarás inactiva profesionalmente
te vas a deprimir y vas a estar
encerrada en tu cuarto quizá por años
por vergüenza
[Música]
según datos de la secretaría de salud en
la última década se registraron 797
amenazas o agresiones solo en 2022 hubo
222 amenazas y se perpetraron 47 ataques
con ácido o alguna otra sustancia por
ahora María Elena estudia música en
Ciudad de México pero debe viajar con
frecuencia a Oaxaca donde sufrió el
atentado para asistir a las audiencias
contra el presunto agresor creo que lo
más fácil hubiera sido callarme pero mi
agresor estaba amenazando de muerte
también a mi familia y creo que como
cualquier persona lo que menos deseamos
es vivir con miedo la diputada Marcela
fuente redactó una iniciativa de ley
para castigar con penas de 8 a 12 años
de cárcel y hasta 30 años se haya
agravantes este tipo de agresiones les
deja una serie de consecuencias físicas
psicológicas no solamente a ellas sino a
sus familias Entonces les desgarran la
vida por eso es importante
promoverla como tentativa de feminicidio
las víctimas cuentan con apoyo de la
sociedad civil como la fundación Carmen
Sánchez que trabaja en conseguir ayuda
emocional y física para la
rehabilitación de la sobrevivientes
gestionamos convenios de colaboración
con el sector privado pero también con
público para acompañarlas en el proceso
médico psicológico legal pero también
propiciamos espacios de esparcimiento
social el caso de María Elena y su ardua
búsqueda de Justicia sigue inspirando a
otras víctimas y a la propia legisladora
a visibilizar esta problemática para que
las mujeres en México no sean atacadas
con ácido
y dentro de las múltiples violencias
sexuales que sufren las mujeres en
Colombia las indígenas alzan su voz las
comunidades lideradas en su mayoría por
hombres justifican la vulneración de sus
derechos Como prácticas ancestrales en
la guajira las wayuu se niegan a aceptar
este destino Marina sardinha y Juanita
González acompañaron a Jazmín Romero de
piayú activista
dos veces intentaron cazar por la fuerza
a Teresa uriana dos veces se escapó de
su ranchería tenía solo 11 años
pata en talla Mario Hentai
[Música]
el matrimonio infantil forzoso dentro
del pueblo wayú sigue siendo una
tradición en algunas familias para la
supervivientes las secuelas perduran en
el tiempo
[Música]
pese al silenciamiento y la
justificación de salvaguardar los usos y
costumbres nuevas generaciones de
mujeres wayú se resisten a esta
ancestralidad patriarcal después de mi
mamá ya entendemos Cuál es la
el vivir de uno pues no no ser violado
pero ya somos libres de violación
yo me he enamorado felizmente de mi
esposo sin perder su identidad a pesar
de las amenazas dentro y fuera de su
comunidad Jazmín Romero y piéyú
activista y feminista indígena wayú hace
su lucha desde el movimiento feminista
de mujeres y niñas con énfasis en las
áreas más remotas y aisladas de la
guajira también asesora a los familiares
de las víctimas de feminicidio como al
profesor Manuel eyeyú padre de Jane y
Elena violada y asesinada en 2021 está
en manos de la justicia ordinaria y que
queremos una respuesta que la
exigibilidad tanto de parte de nosotros
que somos activistas y de parte de
ustedes como acompañamos el proceso a
las víctimas Es que es que actúen ya de
una vez y no dilaten más los casos de
feminicidio es que hay en las
comunidades indígenas su hija tenía 17
años
como en otros casos de feminicidio en la
región el asesino sigue libre y nosotros
pues prácticamente no contamos el
respaldo de la justicia ni del estado en
esa parte
abanderando el feminismo indígena cada
vez son más las mujeres guayu que alzan
la voz desde dentro contra las
opresiones y violencia sexuales en sus
comunidades
y llega el momento del análisis para
ampliarnos sobre estas dinámicas de
violencia sexual y de derechos
reproductivos que acabamos de ver en
América Latina tenemos con nosotras a
Verónica Vera directora ejecutiva de la
asociación feminista surcona en Ecuador
Verónica bienvenida a ella soy y por qué
a pesar de que muchos países están
implementando medidas por ejemplo para
combatir la violencia sexual Los
indicadores No bajan como se esperaría
Cuál sería la propuesta de acción
Hola qué tal Buenos días un gusto
acompañarles y bueno primero decir que
efectivamente lo que vemos es que las
mujeres hemos tenido que luchar y es
gracias a estas mujeres que han luchado
antes de nosotras que hemos logrado
tener derechos no escuchábamos el caso
de Teresa que ahora sus hijas no viven
la situación de violación que ella vivió
justamente porque hubo un cambio
cultural no hubo una educación sexual
alrededor de que la violencia sexual en
contra de ellas no era algo que debería
normalizarse o que debería entenderse
como algo cultural creo que ese es el
primer paso que nos estamos olvidando en
los países el feminismo muchas veces
enfocado en la búsqueda de justicia en
la sanción penal en la cárcel para los
agresores sexuales pero algo que todavía
son deudas pendientes muy grandes en
nuestros países es la prevención y para
la prevención es del trabajo en
educación no la educación contra los
machismos contra las violencias la
educación sexual desde las infancias con
los niños las niñas y también la
educación sexual para los padres y las
madres que están en la crianza de estos
niños que efectivamente a futuro podrían
ser quienes agredan o quienes decidan no
ejercer estas formas de violencia y
contra las niñas también justamente
quienes están en la crianza de niñas
para que nos enseñen que la violencia no
es normal que el amor no puede ser
sinónimo de ninguna forma de violencia
ni de agresión entonces creo que el
reportaje que veíamos Antes nos nos
indicaba que justamente es la cultura la
que debe cambiar es la educación la que
debe priorizarse y eso es lo que va a
hacer que efectivamente en un futuro que
Espero que no sea tan lejano dejemos de
contar estas historias tan dolorosas
Y es que también además se preocupa
muchísimo que el feminicidio está
disparado en toda la región no las las
cifras son altísimas en todos los países
abriendo por México que era el país en
el que veíamos el testimonio de las
mujeres quemadas con ácido y yo quisiera
preguntarle si esto es una muestra de
que las otras violencias están fuera de
control porque al final le tiene que ser
la mayor alerta si la culminación de
todas las violencias que es el
feminicidio es un crimen que está tan
fortalecido en América Latina
efectivamente O sea que los feminicidios
sean algo que es digamos la huella de
nuestra región suceden en todos los
países en México y en Ecuador no nos
quedamos atrás tenemos trescientos
treinta y dos Víctimas de feminicidio y
la mayoría de estos casos están en la
impunidad Entonces el feminicidio muchas
veces hemos dicho que es la punta de
este iceberg de violencias que nos
demuestra que detrás de de esta muerte
violenta de esta mujer de este asesinato
violento hubo una serie de violencias
que el estado no logró prevenir no hubo
violencia seguramente sexual psicológica
física en Ecuador y estoy segura que en
otros países de la región las mujeres
que son Víctimas de femicidio habían
buscado muchas veces medidas de
protección habían puesto una denuncia en
fiscalía y lo que nos está demostrando
el femicidio es que el sistema de
protección de los estados del sistema de
Justicia no está cumpliendo con su labor
de prevenir que que la violencia siga
sucediendo en nuestra contra Entonces yo
diría que efectivamente Y si desde esta
punta del izzer pero que hay muchas
otras violencias todavía que no están
logrados ser logrando ser atendidas de
la manera que debe ser para la
prevención efectivamente de estas
muertes tan dolorosas tan violentas como
son los feminicidios en América Latina y
Verónica yo la veo con su pañuelo verde
que es uno de los grandes estandartes de
las luchas feministas y del 8 de marzo
que acaba de pasar más adelante vamos a
ver un reporte sobre cómo va el aborto
en Argentina y también Sobre qué es lo
que ha pasado en Colombia que se ha
convertido en uno de los países más
progresistas en la materia desde hace un
año Pero antes quiero preguntarle a
usted sobre los avances en materia de
derechos reproductivos
qué tareas tienen pendientes los países
en los que ya hay avances por la
despenalización como los que le acabo de
nombrar Y cómo debe enfocarse la lucha
en países que son muchísimo más
restrictivos caso de Honduras o caso de
República Dominicana
bueno efectivamente en los países donde
ya hemos ganado este derecho porque este
derecho se ha ganado con la lucha de las
mujeres con la lucha feminista el
derecho a poder decidir a poder abortar
lo que hace falta es la implementación
de las políticas públicas o de las leyes
para que cada vez haya menos trabas
cuando nos vayamos al sistema de salud
cuando vayamos a un hospital a exigir
justicia a exigir perdón el acceso a
este derecho no en la interrupción del
embarazo por ahora lo que pasa es que es
el feminismo mismo quien está
acompañando a las mujeres en la búsqueda
de estos abortos legales No todavía nos
toca meter medidas de protección hacer
presión hacer cartas y quejas
administrativas porque no recibimos la
atención adecuada de Los profesionales
de la salud sin juzgamientos sin
presiones ni violencia obstétrica
entonces creo que la implementación es
la gran el gran reto de los países donde
ya hay leyes y donde hay avances también
legales Por otra parte en países donde
no hay avances legales por ejemplo como
República Dominicana como Honduras que
mencionábamos creo que es necesario que
se cumplan los estándares y las
recomendaciones internacionales que ya
se han hecho tenemos miles de
recomendaciones no me podría aterrizar
en alguna en este momento porque son
demasiadas que ya dicen que penalizar el
aborto es una forma de violencia contra
las mujeres que la criminalización de
las mujeres por la interrupción del
embarazo es una forma de violencia y en
algunos casos es una forma que podría
ser considerada tortura entonces hay que
avanzar a que nuestros cuerpos y
nuestras decisiones Dejen de estar
penalizadas y sobre todo hay que
felicitar también los pequeños logros
por ejemplo vimos que este ocho de marzo
en Honduras se logró aprobar la
anticoncepción oral de emergencia y así
Honduras deja de ser uno de los el único
país Perdón en América Latina en donde
estaba prohibida una una pastilla
anticonceptiva y que es de emergencia
justamente para prevenir embarazos en
Casos de violencia sexual y después de
diez años en los que estuvo prohibida ya
Verónica termina el tiempo con usted le
Quiero agradecer y también pues hacer el
último comentario para cerrar digamos
este este Macro de los temas y es que
las maternidades deben ser deseadas y
también entender que el derecho al
aborto no es un tema que solamente nos
inmiscuya a las mujeres que tenemos
privilegio de Educación y al final
herramientas para tomar decisiones sobre
nuestro cuerpo sino las más vulnerables
y las que no tienen acceso y a quienes
el estado no protege Muchas gracias
Verónica Muchas gracias a ti por la
invitación efectivamente continuamos
porque el 21 de febrero de 2022 o
Colombia despenalizó El derecho al
aborto hasta la semana 24 y se convirtió
en el referente Regional de la materia
la sentencia que fue impulsada por el
movimiento causa justa convirtió al país
en uno de los más avanzados en la
legislación de interrupción del embarazo
la despenalización está orientada a
proteger a los cuerpos gestantes con un
especial énfasis en las más vulnerables
que habitan zonas apartadas como las
niñas y las víctimas de abuso un año
después en las colectivas celebran los
avances y continúan su activismo para
que las maternidades sean libres y sean
deseadas
antes del fallo en Colombia el frente de
la lucha por los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos en América Latina durante
estos últimos años ha sido Argentina que
a finales del 2020 logró el aborto libre
y seguro hasta la semana 14 y pasado ese
plazo también lo respeta en Casos de
violación y de riesgo para la madre
desde entonces podemos decir que se ha
avanzado en su implementación no sin
algunas falencias y trabas en el acceso
nuestro corresponsal en Buenos Aires
natalio cosoy nos cuenta más
en el servicio obstetricia que dirige
Analía messina a las personas gestantes
pueden acceder a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta las 14
semanas de gestación pero en ciertos
casos también pueden abortar después de
ese lapso de tiempo en este consultorio
se hace toda la parte de asesoramiento
consejería y se entrega la medicación el
cambio en la ley no solo vino acompañado
de un mejor acceso a la práctica sino
también de mejor provisión de insumos
incluido el tratamiento de medicamentos
combinados recomendados por la
Organización Mundial de la Salud por
suerte contamos ahora con vipac que es
mifepristona más misoprostol También
tenemos misoprostol que es un insumo
absolutamente imprescindible que el
aborto tenga lugar en este contexto
permite además Dar seguimiento a los
casos que lo necesitan es que uno de los
objetivos de la ley era reducir la
mortalidad y las secuelas en personas
que abortan al ofrecer un marco seguro
para la práctica en un creciente número
de sectores de salud Hoy hay 144 tres
centros de salud y hospitales públicos
que garantizan ivehila en todo el país
es un 60 más de lo que estaba declarado
60% más de lo que estaba declarado en
2020 que eran 903 cuando se registran
las muertes relacionados aborto estamos
en el en el momento más bajo y hubo una
reducción del 40 por ciento pero a pesar
de estos avances Todavía existen
barreras en algunos casos como cuenta
Liliana piñeiro que pertenece a una red
autogestionada que brinda apoyo y
acompañamiento a personas que quieren
abortar si bien hay más equipos y todo
también hay más personas objetoras
dentro de esos espacios llevándolo
adelante no entonces hay dilación
el hecho de hacerles esperar generar
estudios que no son necesarios tal vez
tan es así que en 2021 con la ley ya
vigente socorristas en Red brindó
acompañamiento a más de 11.500 personas
en toda Argentina que quisieron abortar
ya hemos hecho una evaluación de las
violencias en América Latina y ahora
vamos a pasar al último segmento de este
especial de ella Soy hablando del debate
en torno a la legalización o a La
abolición de la prostitución que se
mantiene muy activo en América Latina y
que genera además grandes brechas en el
feminismo para dar voz a todos los
puntos de vista primero vamos a contar
con Sara Jaramillo Gómez quien es
abogada y representante del colectivo
abolicionista de Medellín en Colombia y
en unos momentos veremos también los
testimonios de regulacionistas comienzo
con Sara Gracias a usted por estar en
ellas hoy
Hola muy buenas tardes a todos Cómo
están gracias al Canal por abrir
los micrófonos
si el debate digamos es álgido es
necesario es importante que Comencemos a
tener estos estas conversaciones cierto
a nivel internacional
La abolición de la prostitución parte de
una premisa fundamental y es que las
mujeres seamos consideradas como seres
humanos como seres que tiene cuentan con
una dignidad que debe ser entendida y
garantizada por el estado en ese sentido
partimos también de otra premisa Y es
que ninguna mujer tiene precio y que la
mayoría de mujeres que en este momento
se encuentran en contextos de
prostitución no lo hacen por el
consentimiento la libertad de elegirlo o
porque sea digamos un espacio que la
ayude a concretar con sus proyectos de
vida sino que lo hacen por necesidad
económica y es precisamente esta
necesidad económica la que termina
anulando ese consentimiento que
supuestamente pues se da a la hora de
Ingresar a este escenario que es
violento y que el sistema prostituyente
en sí mismo No es más que la expresión
de la violencia machista y de la
cosificación sobre los cuerpos de las
mujeres feminismo actualmente lucha por
eso bueno unas partes del feminismo No
porque si hay que tener muy claro que
esto genera muchísimas divisiones entre
las propias feministas pero también hay
que tener claro que el ambiente de la
prostitución es un ambiente dominado por
el proxenetismo y yo aquí quiero
preguntarles Sara Por qué considera o
descarta más bien la abolicionismo que
sea posible regular la prostitución y
darle el título de trabajo sexual como
abogan otras compañeras
bueno La regulación como tal no responde
de manera suficiente a los
planteamientos que se plantean a la hora
de esos a la hora de analizar esos
escenarios violentos de la prostitución
en principio porque la violencia no se
acaba por la forma de vinculación que
tengan estas personas que mucha que
muchas veces son mujeres Víctimas de
trata de personas y tampoco logra
responder Pues precisamente como a las
demandas de Derechos Humanos que tiene
el movimiento feminista dentro del marco
jurídico Entonces digamos que es
insuficiente la La regulación
precisamente por por eso porque nosotras
digamos desde la perspectiva
evolucionista lo que buscamos es
analizar la prostitución como ese
escenario violento que es atacar la
demanda de prostitución el problema no
es de las víctimas digamos o de las
mujeres que están en prostitución en
este momento sino que analizamos la
existencia Constitución porque hay una
demanda y partimos también de que
entrara garantizar
digamos
esa premisa de garantizar derechos
laborales para las mujeres que están en
prostitución no es más que una máscara
para ocultar lo que hay detrás Y es
garantizar un derecho que tienen los
hombres acceder cuerpos de mujeres y eso
es lo que está mal y eso es lo que hay
que critica La abolición y me plantea
precisamente un modelo en el que podamos
atender a las mujeres que en este
momento están en prostitución para que
cumplan sus sueños para que sean
reconocidas como mujeres que pueden
soñar y puedan concretar un proyecto de
vida digno en la sociedad y persiga y
sancione al proxenetismo y a quienes
demandan prostitución bien Sara ya nos
estamos casi quedando sin tiempo para
esta entrevista me queda tiempo para una
pregunta más también haciendo la
reflexión para nuestros televidentes
sobre la trata de personas no que son
casos que no están regulados que no
están bien verificados y en los que
normalmente una víctima plátano va a
admitir que es una víctima de trata así
que es muy difícil aplicar unas medidas
que regulen y que nos permitan
distinguir quienes quisieran según las
los puntos de vista regulacionistas
hacer parte de la prostitución y quienes
están ahí porque están bajo obligación y
bajo amenaza pero más allá de estas
posturas activistas yo quisiera
hablarles ahora de la preocupación común
que existe en las diversas colectivas y
es el bienestar de las mujeres que están
en prostitución aunque con unos enfoques
que son ampliamente distintos Usted cree
que hay esperanza de hallar puntos de
encuentro Porque el feminismo es una
gran lucha pero fragmentada
bueno puntos de encuentro en el sentido
de que siento que en la medida en que
las propuestas que se entren a defender
versen sobre el bienestar de las
víctimas de trata de la sobrevivientes y
de reconocer también dentro del mundo de
la prostitución pues que no todas lo
hacen porque quieren y que eso de hecho
a esas personas o esas mujeres que se
nombran Desde esa manera representan una
gran minoría dentro del colectivo de
mujeres que está ahí por necesidad y por
hambre Entonces el punto de encuentro es
ese los Derechos Humanos pues Sara mire
Yo le agradezco mucho por traernos su
punto de vista que es valioso y que
enriquece el debate ya Se nos acabó el
tiempo y la deseo que tenga buena
jornada
Muchas gracias y para nuestro cierre
pues vamos a ver el punto de vista de
Lourdes Torres quien se define como
trabajadora sexual y que defiende los
derechos de sus compañeras quieran o no
salir de esta práctica la historia es de
Gustavo Ortega
ayudamos a las personas mujeres
positivas con VIH Lourdes Torres líder
de la asociación prodefensa de la mujer
se declara activista por los derechos de
las mujeres y busca apoyo ante la falta
de un marco jurídico de protección para
esta actividad en Ecuador mientras lo
consigue Lourdes ayuda también a las
familias de mujeres en situación de
prostitución un término que ella no
comparte y prefiere el de trabajadoras
sexuales es el caso de solange Benavides
a quien la asociación patrocinó sus
estudios luego del fallecimiento de su
madre una ex trabajadora sexual al
activismo de las trabajadoras sexuales
en les debo mi educación
les debo un plata de comida que llegaba
a mi casa
mi mamá bueno con apoyo de la señora lo
des Torres pudo salir del trabajo sexual
este día Lourdes asiste a una audiencia
en un tribunal de Quito para presentar
una acción de protección a favor de
cuatro mil de ellas un la legalización y
el reconocimiento del trabajo sexual y
deber de ver que la de la situación que
también seamos parte del seguro social y
también de saber que que tenemos el
mismo derecho todo para de ser una
ciudad igual que todas
en un club nocturno funciona la
asociación María prepara la comida para
las mujeres antes de iniciar su jornada
en otro piso contiguo Natalia está a
cargo del desarrollo de programas piloto
enfocados en asesoría legal y apoyo a
quienes deseen abandonar la actividad en
el país según Natalia hay 70.000
establecimientos como los llama el
Ministerio de salud pública donde se
ejerce esta actividad la asociación
prodefensa de la mujer en sí lo que
hemos retomado es el tema de ayudar y
guiar a las chicas en el tema de
derechos Aunque la prostitución en
Ecuador no es ilegal no hay una
regulación de protección de sus derechos
sólo se practica en lugares denominados
casas de tolerancia Lourdes cuestiona
que no garantizan la integridad física
psicológica o una vida libre de
violencia cada día Estas mujeres pueden
ser Víctimas de explotación sexual o
abuso de las autoridades
con mucha información para pensar fuera
de la pantalla llegamos al finales de
este especial de ella Soy por el 8m
muchas mujeres lo hicieron posible la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Alba Santana y de Jennifer Guevara y
la coordinación es de corresponsales por
herminia Fernández la producción de
invitados la realizó Laura Espinosa
Gracias a ustedes por vernos y vivas nos
queremos
[Música]